This is a bonito rim. It's made from that activity
. It's said that the moonless food is the hardest food in
the world.
I have been
manufacturing bonito flakes for 30 years. If you don't have
hair, it's the
basis of Japanese food, isn't it?
Katsuobushi used to be used as a so-called topping, but it was used as a so-called topping, but it was used as a so-called topping,
and after that, it was used with miso soba.
It is widely used in udon and
bonito. The place where dried bonito is produced is about 90% or more in Kagoshima prefecture, Shizuoka prefecture, but
there is a crush everywhere in the country
. This factory is called Yamashi Co., Ltd.
At the factory, about 70 to 75 tons of bonito flakes are produced each month, and
about 900 tons of raw materials are processed annually
.  Then
[Music]
It's dried by applying heat
. After drying, it's sprayed with bonito flakes and lit for about 4 months or so, and
then 2 deaths are completed.
I think I'm declining in age, because it's
mechanized, so to be honest, we're in an era where we don't need a writer or bonito,
so we're raw with bonito in that way.  The number of bonito flakes is steadily
decreasing.
After all, I feel that we are responsible for the basis of the Japanese food tradition
.
Well, I'm very wondering if I should continue doing this.  Katsuobushi
[Music]